hello my los angeles friends and
i was gonna say family but i don't have
any family here so
friends hello
you hi how are you hope you're doing
awesome i had a little too much coffee
this morning so
trying to calm down anyway i wanted to
tell you about a meet-up as i reach for
the book
josh sundquist
just released his paperback version of
his book just don't fall and he will be
here in los angeles this thursday from 7
00 to 8 30 at the borders and century
city in la all the info is below here in
the description click on the rsvp link
if you're gonna go i look forward to
seeing you guys all there i'm super
excited because josh is awesome and is
probably one of my favorite youtubers so
come say hi get an autograph get a
picture i don't know what else josh has
planned so
come and find out josh sundquist here i
hope to see you this thursday in los
angeles at 7 pm at borders century city
i'm going to be talking about my book
just don't fall answering your questions
yes what's your favorite dance move
and giving out free t-shirts interesting
side note this is actually not my hair
it's a stock photo that my publisher
bought online which means that somewhere
out there is a model who's gonna walk
into barnes and noble and be like
that forehead looks really familiar
all right hope to see you on thursday i
hope to see you guys all there no
excuses if you have a car
drive if you're far away i'll see you
soon bye